did they get along when they were
younger was there at nothing no they
didn't never know they shared a bedroom
he shared a bedroom when I pissed he
bought this new sound system and I've
been out drinking like about 15 and up
maybe a little too many Chevy's and I've
come in and another spliff as well I
made [ __ ] room was spinning I've got
out of bed on the [ __ ] wall with the
[ __ ] like it
right I can't find the light switch for
our [ __ ] it was kind of the goal mouth
so I just whipped out a stall all these
[ __ ] new sound system yeah aha Likud
it and he's done that where the [ __ ] are
you doing I was a seven everybody
envisioned it he's I'm a [ __ ] new
[ __ ] stereo as are those are your
[ __ ] gyro it oh and I think that's
where I think yours are good for that
was a long time ago and you're not
kidding you think that that pissing
incident where you peed all over his new
Santa and oh forget he was a kid who
hung out in his bedroom that sound
system was that all right I was a Holy
Grail yeah yeah anybody got a go you got
go mate yes and that's I mean I pissed
in my padding and badge honors but no
one did you ever exactly did you ever
apologize to your brother for peeing and
his sound equipment did you ever say
listen yeah olicity I was drunk I was 15
for Christ's sakes I apologize can we
get past that I said listen my thought
it was even the sound system or your
[ __ ] at your mouth I know we seek
city's mouth for fees you take off of
you leave it my son